it's
zooming back out to the philosophical
you said that numerai is uh
very much like wall street pets uh
is is there i i think it'd be
interesting to dig in why you think so
i think you're speaking to the
distributed nature of the two
and the the power of the people nature
of the two
so maybe can you speak to the
similarities and the differences
and in which way is nimrod more powerful
in which way is wall street bets more
powerful
yeah this is why the wall street bet
story is so interesting to me because
it's like
feels like we're connected yeah um and
looking at how
just looking at the forum of wall street
bets it's i was
talking earlier about how how can you
make credible claims
you're anonymous okay well maybe you can
take a screenshot how
or maybe you can upvote someone maybe
you can have karma
on reddit and those kinds of things make
this emerging
thing possible numerai
it didn't work at all when we started it
didn't work at
all why people made multiple accounts
they
made really random models and hoped they
would get lucky and some of them did
yes staking was our like solution
to could we could we make it so that we
could
trust we could know which model people
believed in the most
and we could wait models that had high
stake
more and effectively coordinate this
group of people
to be like well actually there's no
incentive to creating bot accounts
anymore
either i stake my accounts in which case
i should believe in them because i could
lose my stake
or i don't and that's a very powerful
thing
that having a negative incentive and a
positive incentive
can make can make things a lot better
and staking is like this
is this really nice like key thing about
blockchain there's like something
special
you can do where they're not even
trusting us with their stake in some
ways
they're trusting the blockchain right um
so
the incentives like you say it's about
making these perfect incentives
so that you can have coordination to
solve one problem
and nowadays i i sleep easy
because i have less money in my own
hedge fund
than our users are staking
on their models that's powerful in some
sense from a human
psychology perspective it's fascinating
that the wall street bets worked at all
right that the the amidst that chaos
emerging behavior
uh like behavior that made sense emerged
it would be fascinating to think if
numerai style
staking could then be transferred to
places like reddit you know and not
necessarily for financial investments
but uh
like i wish sometimes people would
you know would have to stake something
in the comments they make
on the internet yeah like that's that's
the problem with anonymity
is like anonymity is freedom and power
that you don't have to
you can speak your mind but it's too
easy to just be shitty
exactly and so this the i mean you're
making me realize from
like a profoundly philosophical
aspect numerous staking is a really
clean way to solve this problem
it's it's a really beautiful way of
course it only with pneumonia currently
works for a very particular problem
right not for human
interaction on the internet but that's
fascinating yeah there's nothing
for to stop people in fact we've open
sourced like the code we use for staking
in a protocol we call erasure um and
any if reddit wanted to they could even
use that code
to do have have enabled staking on um
our wall street bets and they're
actually researching now they've had
some ethereum grants
on how could they have more crypto stuff
in there in ethereum because wouldn't
that be interesting
like imagine you could um instead of
seeing a screenshot
like guys i promise i will not uh
sell my gamestop we're just gonna go
huge
we're not going to sell at all
and here is a smart contract
which no one in the world including me
can
undo that says my i have staked
millions against this claim um
that's powerful and then what could you
do
and of course it doesn't have to be
millions it could be just very small
amount but then
just a huge number of users doing that
kind of stake exactly
that you know that could change the
internet it would change and demand wall
street
they would not they would never have
been able to they would still be
short squeezing one day off to the next
every single hedge fund collapsing
you